LOGAN URY: Hi, my
name is Logan Ury.
And I'm on the Irrational Lab
team, a behavioral economics
research team led by Dan Ariely.
I'm very excited
to welcome my dear
friend Joey the Cat to Google.
A former teen prodigy
in the Chuck E. Cheese
skeeball circuit, Joey the Cat
turned pro in the fall of 2009
and quickly made
a name for himself
in the Brewskee-Ball
nationwide tour.
At 24 he continued to push
the statistical limits
and was the first SF roller to
capture a triple Crown, which
is the BROTY, the Brewskee
Mug and Hundo Challenge.
The records kept coming and Joey
the Cat could not be stopped.
In 2001, in a field of the
world's 64 best rollers,
Joey the Cat dominated
the competition
and was crowned the number
one skeeball player.
He won again in 2012
and 2014 and is now
the most acclaimed competitive
skeeball player on the planet.
In 2013 he quit
his cushy tech job
to focus full-time on his
skeeball rental business.
He's here to talk to
you about how you too
can turn your passion
into a career.
Joey, thanks for being with us.
JOEY MUCHA: Logan,
thanks for having me.
LOGAN URY: So I thought
it'd be fun to start off
with a little audience
participation.
And maybe somebody
can challenge Joey
to a little skeeball match.
DAVID: Oh my god.
All right.
It's been a long time.
So ball nine?
JOEY MUCHA: Ball nine, yeah.
DAVID: Holy crap.
All right.
We're on a time limit.
I don't have a strategy.
LOGAN URY: [INAUDIBLE]
JOEY MUCHA: The first three
balls were a little wide.
Still trying to find the center.
Oh there we go.
DAVID: There we go.
JOEY MUCHA: [INAUDIBLE] 50.
Two 50s.
Almost had it dialed
in for a second there
but strayed left and right.
Nine balls through, 220.
LOGAN URY: Woo.
JOEY MUCHA: 220.
[INAUDIBLE]
DAVID: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JOEY MUCHA: What
we call finding 40.
We go right down
the middle and try
to roll [INAUDIBLE]
[? best ?] seven as possible.
[INAUDIBLE] So that you
can get your average high
over 10 games.
We would play 10 games in a row.
[INAUDIBLE] centered out the 40.
Sometimes you have
trouble with 50.
But in this case nice and
smooth right down the middle.
LOGAN URY: Woo.
JOEY MUCHA: Thank you.
LOGAN URY: Nicely done.
David, thanks for participating.
DAVID: No problem.
LOGAN URY: OK, Joey.
So I'm going to ask you
questions for a little while
and then at the end we'll
open it up to the audience.
So let's start by talking
about your love of skeeball.
Then we'll talk about
the skeeball business.
And we'll wrap it
up with your advice
for budding entrepreneurs.
So first of all,
who are you and who
is your alter-
"skeego," Joey the Cat?
JOEY MUCHA: My name is Joey
Mucha and born and raised
in Portland, Oregon.
Moved to San Francisco
six years ago.
And when I moved
to San Francisco
I joined a competitive
skeeball league.
And everyone has
an alter "skeego"
when they join the
league, because it's
sort of escapism and
something fun to do.
And so the alter "skeego"
that I employed in the league
was Joey the Cat, which
was given to me in college.
And it's sort of a metaphor
for always being on the prowl,
keeping your claws sharp-- both
in personal and professional
endeavors.
LOGAN URY: Fresh suit.
I like it.
JOEY MUCHA: Thanks.
LOGAN URY: And I guess my
second question is why skeeball.
JOEY MUCHA: Skeeball
came to me--
as you mentioned--
from Chuck E. Cheese.
I was in the arcade for my
11th birthday with my family
and friends.
And I was wandering
around the arcade.
And my dad was hovering
around the skeeball machines.
And he said, Joey, you
should play this game.
It's really interactive.
And you're not just
staring at a screen
pushing buttons and
shooting fake things.
You're rolling something
tangible up the ramp.
And there's instant
gratification.
And that planted the seed
for my skeeball love.
LOGAN URY: And can you tell us
a little bit about your journey
to the national championship?
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah when I joined
the competitive skeeball league
when I moved here I fell
in love with the game
and playing with friends.
And I excelled pretty well but
not the best in San Francisco.
I was a top seed
from San Francisco--
and invite the top 64 rollers
to come out and compete.
And so I go to the national
championship in New York City.
So I'm flying across the country
to play competitive skeeball.
And I go out there and
I was a "hundo roller."
I was rolling for the
100-point pockets.
And I was quickly
met with adversity.
And I ended up losing
in the third round
to the eventual
champion, Skee-Diddy.
LOGAN URY: He'll always get you.
JOEY MUCHA: Skee-Diddy.
And so when I come
back to San Francisco
after the national
championships I really
went back to the drawing board.
I had to reevaluate my game.
And so what I did
right after that
was I said, all
right, the only way
to get better at this
game-- I'm living
in Bernal Heights, a
one-bedroom apartment--
and I went onto eBay
and I said, maybe
I got to buy my own
skeeball machine.
And I end up shipping
out a skeeball machine
into my apartment.
And so that was losing
the national championship
and then figuring
out how to get better
and owning your own
skeeball machine.
LOGAN URY: So how often
were you practicing?
JOEY MUCHA: I was practicing
three, four times a week,
and really becoming a student
of the game and the sport.
LOGAN URY: And the
next year did you
go back and claim
that championship?
JOEY MUCHA: So yeah there's a
couple of videos on YouTube,
some Rocky-inspired training
videos of me practicing,
and reminiscing on the
prior year's failure,
and then climbing up to
the top of Bernal Heights
with skeeballs in
my hand and posting
that to YouTube to send
a message that I've
been practicing a lot.
And I went back and my
mom-- her birthday falls
around Memorial Day, when the
skeeball national championships
are every year-- and she said,
all I want for my birthday
is a skeeball national
championship for my son.
So really set the pressure high.
But I clawed my way through
the field and pulled it out.
And in the very last match--
you roll 10 games in a row,
alternating with your
opponent, one on one.
And so as I was mentioning,
in the little exhibition
round we had here, you need
to keep your average high.
So if you miss the 100s, or
you're going really ambitious
and you miss, it's going to
create a pretty volatile score.
And then if someone who's
steady, right down the middle,
is going to keep their average
higher and service to the top.
And so I won it.
And there's a speech
online, and also on YouTube,
where I dedicate it to my mom,
winning my first ever national
skeeball championship.
LOGAN URY: And what did
it feel like to win?
JOEY MUCHA: It was electric.
It was so gratifying to
practice really, really hard
and commit myself to
this game and focus--
I was so focused and
dialed in that it
was special on so many levels.
Not only being around
all my friends,
but the energy in the
room, the community
that is a part of the
skeeball league is electric.
And it was just so much fun.
And then shaking up
that champagne bottle,
spraying it around the bar where
the tournament was being held,
and then dedicating
it to my mom.
LOGAN URY: That's beautiful.
Felt
JOEY MUCHA: Amazing.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
Do you have any favorite
skeeball stories
that you want to share with us?
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah.
So a couple of
skeeball stories I've
got-- not related to
the business, I guess--
is going back to the second
national championships.
And my parents actually flew
out from Portland, Oregon
to New York City
to watch me play.
So not only did my
mom ask me, can you
dedicate the championship
to my birthday,
she says, can we come
out and watch you.
It was one of two
rollers that also
had their parents in attendance.
They probably didn't travel
as far across the country.
But having my parents out
there to enlighten them
to this experience was really
special because not only
did my dad get me
into the game he's
so supportive of me playing.
And my mom was so excited to
see all of these victories
and then come out
and watch it live.
And she was so nervous.
She said, I don't know how
you stay calm under pressure
up there, because there
were multiple times
during the third
national championship
that I competed in where
she had to turn away.
And there was so much pressure.
And there were three
times that I almost lost.
So you have to go from
64 rollers down to two
and then play for the title
and basically win out.
And there were two
matches where I
was down by a handful of
points in frame seven, eight
against "Brewbacca,"
"Snakes on a Lane,"
and then ultimately
"Chips Ahoy" was
the guy I played in the finals.
And my parents were right there.
And I handily won that
second national championship
in the final round.
LOGAN URY: This sounds like
a movie waiting to happen.
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah there's a
documentary in the works.
There's a fair amount of
interesting storylines,
and interesting
characters, and then
some drama on the competitive
side and the business side.
LOGAN URY: Yeah so that's a good
transition into the business
side.
Can you tell us a little bit
about what you're doing before?
JOEY MUCHA: So I
moved to San Francisco
to work for an internet
technology company.
And I jumped in as an
online marketing manager
having never been to
the Bay Area other
than to look for housing.
And it was fantastic.
I worked for this company
for a couple years.
And then they ended
up getting acquired
by a larger mobile
advertising network.
And all along the way I was
running the skeeball biz
on the side.
And then I went and worked
for another company.
And then they got acquired
by a publicly-traded company.
And so I was achieving a
certain amount of success--
I mean nothing astronomical.
I was a early employee but
not a significant shareholder.
But learning a ton, both
about business, and strategy,
and navigating the
professional landscape,
but also building my
marketing and sales chops.
LOGAN URY: So how did skeeball
transform from a hobby
to a business for you?
JOEY MUCHA: When I bought that
first skeeball machine that's
when people started
calling me crazy.
They said, why do you have
your own skeeball machine.
What are you doing?
You're not an arcade operator.
You don't run the league.
Why do you have this machine?
And so I said, it's to practice
and because I love the game.
And then it wasn't until I
had my very first client that
wanted to rent this machine from
me for a company anniversary
that I figured there is a
business behind this game.
It's niche enough and
in enough demand--
and I can create enough demand--
that people would potentially
want to have these at events
and have me host tournaments.
And so it was that
point when I realized
it could become a side
business, when I said,
there is a small
market for this.
And so I pursued that.
And I reinvested all the
money I got from the rentals
back into the side business.
LOGAN URY: Was there a pivotal
moment or a pivotal company
where you said, this is a
real thing that I can do.
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah when I rented
my first machine to Airbnb
for their second
anniversary party.
Airbnb is a home-sharing
rentals marketplace.
And I became a host on Airbnb.
And the hook to my
space-- why someone
would want to rent
my space, other
than the
terribly-uncomfortable couch
that they were
staying on-- was I
had a skeeball machine
inside my apartment.
So I said, rent a
couch or skeeball
machine in Bernal Heights.
And at the time
Airbnb was growing
very rapidly but still small.
And the CEO was
living on Airbnb.
And so he stayed
at my apartment.
And when he saw the
skeeball machine in there
he was just enamored
with my story
and with the novelty of this
large-- it was a 13-footer.
This is a 10-footer
you see right here.
So it's even three feet
longer on the lane which
makes it even more of a
overwhelming furniture
piece in your small
one-bedroom apartment.
Because I had to step over
it to get into my kitchen.
I had to walk around it
to get into my bedroom.
It was blocking one of my doors.
And so he said, we need this at
our second anniversary party.
And so we made it happen.
We put it inside the
original Airbnb office,
which was also their apartment.
And so it had this very
homey-- like from one
small business
budding entrepreneur
to a growing small business
inside their apartment.
And then people just had
so much joy playing it.
LOGAN URY: So you talked about
your companies being acquired.
The question of my mind
is, do you actually
make a living from
your skeeball business.
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah absolutely.
Right now it's my
primary source of income.
Sometimes I'll rent
my place out on Airbnb
for a little bit of
supplemental income.
But the majority of my income
comes from this business--
renting, leasing, and
hosting skeeball tournaments.
LOGAN URY: So walk us through
a typical work day for you.
JOEY MUCHA: A typical work
day for me is waking up,
answering emails,-- either
inbound leads coming in from
the website or outbound sales
efforts that I'm working
on-- a couple hours of email,
and then I'm either delivering
skeeball machines to events,
or servicing skeeball machines,
or going around to skeeball
machines and collecting
the passive income that's coming
in to the machines that are
in bars and venues.
LOGAN URY: And did you
always see yourself
as an entrepreneur?
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah
my personal DNA was
wired to always be hands-on,
whether that was starting
companies or building things.
And when I was in college
I never skateboarded before
and I wanted to skateboard
for the first time.
So instead of just
buying a skateboard
I started researching on the
web how to make skateboards.
And then I figured out how to
take the thin laminates of wood
and put them together
into these molds,
and then cut them
out, and install
the graphics and the hardware.
And the next thing
you know I was
building 5, 10
skateboards a month
and just selling them to friends
and having fun with that.
And then-- a lot of people
do this but-- silkscreening
t-shirts and just
creating your own wares
that you want to interact with.
And then skeeball came around.
And it was a no-brainer for me
that it could be a business.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
What has surprised you most
about working for yourself?
JOEY MUCHA: The most
surprising thing
for me is that when you run
your own company full-time
you think you're going to
have all this free time.
And you think you're going
to have way more flexibility.
And it's absolutely
the opposite.
Because you end up having
to work even harder and even
longer hours to really make
your venture pay dividends.
You could just make ends meet,
and put in the minimum amount,
if your business is
already generating revenue.
But to make it really
grow and thrive you
have to start finding
efficiencies, and hiring
people, and positioning
your assets so they
can work for you as
best as possible.
But that takes a
lot of hard work
with sales, and marketing,
and partnerships.
And so when I quit
my job I said,
all right, I'm going to have
all this time to travel and take
on other projects.
But it was quite the opposite.
I was working even
harder and not
doing some of my other pastimes
to get the business to where
I wanted it, because I was
very ambitious with where
I wanted it.
LOGAN URY: Is there one
aspect of your business
that you're
particularly proud of?
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah.
So the passive side of
the business, where I just
put games into venues, bars,
art galleries, food truck
parks, and they work for me.
It was how Warren Buffett sort
of initiated his base capital
to grow his empire, was
through passive income
streams-- gumball machines
and vending machines.
And so putting them into bars
has an incredibly long sales
cycle because you need to
become friends with the owners
and convince them that
the space in their bars
is something that you can
take up to not only provide
an amenity to the patron but
make money off of that space.
And so one story that
I'm really proud of
is building a skeeball trailer.
So I took two skeeball
machines, cut the legs off,
and put them on
a utility trailer
that you'd pull
around lawnmowers
with-- like a
landscaping trailer.
And I just cut the legs
off the skeeball machine
and plopped them right
onto the trailer.
And it required not
only hands-on skills
with building things but
also business development.
I had to figure out where
is this thing going to live.
I don't have a garage.
I don't have storage for it.
And how's it going
to make money?
And so very early on I
partnered with a food truck park
that is basically pioneering, in
San Francisco, the mobile food
truck ecosystem.
And they housed my
skeeball trailer
once I completed it so it could
stay there semi-permanently.
And I could take it out
and drive it around.
LOGAN URY: So you
talked a little bit
about how it was surprising
that you actually
have less time
rather than more time
now that you run
your own business.
What are some other
surprises and challenges
of working for yourself?
JOEY MUCHA: So when
you work for yourself
you basically have
to do everything,
from operations, to sales, to
HR, to taking out the trash.
And you can't be ashamed
of taking on those tasks.
And if you're literally
working for yourself--
and you're the only employee--
you have to do everything.
And so hiring an
accountant was something
I didn't think I
would have to do.
I could just learn some
accounting software
and figure it out.
But if you're not good at that
you need to bring on some help.
And so figuring out
what tools I needed
to use to make
myself most efficient
was something that surprised me
and I had to explore and learn.
And so I'm using
an array of tools
that make my job
more efficient, which
is like an accounting online
accounting software called
Xero, a credit card acceptor
called Stripe, and Google Apps
to manage all of my sales
reps' email accounts
and calendaring so I have
my scheduling all in place.
And sort of a variety
of web-based tools.
And then having a website.
I was incredibly surprised
how much inbound sales leads
I was getting just by being
really highly-indexed.
LOGAN URY: How do
people find you?
JOEY MUCHA: The
two primary sources
are my website, via
Google Search, and Yelp.
Yelp has been an incredible
inbound lead source.
LOGAN URY: So I'd
like to transition
into giving advice to people.
I think there's a lot of people
at Google who enjoy their jobs
but also have a big passion.
And I think they have
some questions around how
do you turn your
passion into a career.
So to start off,
what's the best career
advice you've ever been given.
JOEY MUCHA: I mean it's
cheesy but doing something
that you love is so critical.
Because if it doesn't keep you
up at night-- if you're not
passionate about
it, you're not going
to pour your heart
into it, and you're not
going to take all
of your free time
and really spend that
time doing this thing.
And you may not
fall in love with it
until you know that
it can be successful
or that it has
potential to grow.
And until you really
give it a chance--
and if it doesn't
keep you up at night,
and you're not proud to
go up to someone and say,
this is what I'm doing or this
is what I want to be doing.
And even walking up to
a stranger and saying,
I'm the best seamstress
who makes leather pants.
Like whatever it is, like
something obscure or something
mundane but you
apply a twist to,
then you're going to have
a hard time selling it.
You're going have a hard
time telling someone that,
oh I quit my XYZ
to do this thing,
unless you are really,
really excited about it.
LOGAN URY: So most
people are not
national champions of anything.
Do you think you really have
to be the best in your fields
in order to go and
pursue that career?
JOEY MUCHA: In my
case, I excelled
from a performance perspective.
But I did other things that
made me more memorable.
If I wasn't a national champion,
but I'm wearing a cat suit
and have this great brand,
and people remember you
as the x for y-- I'm the
skeeball guy for rentals--
and that is more critical
than being some novel
performance in culture.
You need to be the subject
matter expert, basically.
You need to be someone that,
when you leave that room,
they're going to
say, I know to go
to that person for this
thing, whatever it is.
If it's iPhone apps,
if it's fixing cars,
if it's building motorcycles,
if it's your cobbler
and you're like the shoe
expert-- born-again shoe
expert.
Whatever it is, you need to
be that person for that trade,
but not be afraid
that you're not
going to be that the next day.
It's going to take time.
It took me three years to say,
I'm going to quit my day job,
my cushy six-figure salary,
to do this thing that's
going to make me
not very much money
but I'm going to have
100% ownership in it.
And you have to put in the time.
And so it takes time to grow.
This is a ball of clay
that you need to mold.
And it's going to
change direction.
I thought I wanted to
start skeeball leagues
and copy what they were doing.
But no.
I've created three other
businesses, the rentals.
And so you need to be creative
with the way your business
or your idea adapts
to the marketplace.
LOGAN URY: Can you
talk a little bit more
about personal branding
and who Joey the Cat is?
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah so Joey
the Cat was just a nickname.
And that's really
all it was when
I gave it to this skeeball
league operator and said,
I'm Joey the Cat.
And then I got
better at skeeball
and it just sort of suck.
And I said, well
people are calling
me Joey the Cat in the
context of skeeball.
So I'm just going to call it
Joey the Cat Skeeball Rentals.
And then I started to employ
some of my creative marketing
tactics against that.
I built a small brand.
I partnered with a designer.
I paid him next to
nothing to build a logo.
And then he designed
t-shirts for me
that had a really
fun, playful nature.
I went into all these
creative exercises
that made the
brand come to life.
And so one of the t-shirts--
I always wore a fanny pack.
And anybody can
wear a fanny pack.
But if you own it, and the
fanny pack is your thing,
and you've got all
your trinkets in there,
and you wear it when you're
in competition or doing
your craft.
I started to make
that part of my brand.
So I have this t-shirt that
has a silkscreened fanny
pack on it.
And people really wanted that
t-shirt because they're like,
oh is that a
functional fanny pack.
No, its just a goofy fanny pack.
But it has your logo on it.
And my business cards was a
great creative exploration.
I think I have some on me.
It's a coaster.
My clientele were bars.
And so I could take
these to a bar.
And it's a letterpress coaster,
which is kind of a lost trade.
And it basically is something
I could leave at a bar
and not feel inappropriate
to give that to a bar owner.
And so I started to remove
friction with my brand
to get to the people
I wanted to talk to.
And then the third thing is I'm
wearing a cat suit right now.
I'm owning this brand.
The first Joey the
Cat attire that I had
was a African women's
jumpsuit onesie
that I got on Haight Street
at a second-hand store.
But it was the most iconic
skeeball performance attire
that anyone was wearing.
And so it was very memorable.
And then I retired that to
the skeeball memorabilia
hall of fame and then upgraded
to this thing, a three piece
custom tailored Sumatra
tiger cat suit, which
has just not only been an
interesting piece of clothing
to wear but has become my brand.
You will never forget this suit.
It's going to be etched
into your eyes forever.
LOGAN URY: I apologize.
JOEY MUCHA: And yes
apologies all around.
But if you want to
remember who that was,
it was either the
guy in the cat suit
or the guy with the skeeball
machine, or in this case
the guy in the cat suit who
brought the skeeball machine.
And that piece of
information that
stays with you will create what
marketers call brand recall.
And it separates
you from the crop
of people that are trying to
do whatever is-- in this case,
arcade games are a commodity.
It's a commoditized
product that I've
differentiated through
branding and creating demand
within the marketplace.
LOGAN URY: It's
really interesting
to hear you talk about what
a role personal branding has
played.
Are there any people you
look up to who you think
are really excelling at this?
JOEY MUCHA: There's a band that
I follow called Con Bro Chill.
And they have a type of
music called party rock.
And even if you
don't love the music,
if you see them live-- they
even make this metaphor
towards burning their
image into your eyes.
They have so much creativity
with the way they perform
and the way their stage presence
is transacted to the audience
that it's infectious.
And it has this viral nature.
And then they live it.
They live it on Twitter.
They live it in their
videos that they create.
And it just permeates
the entire experience.
And the songs get you going.
But if you're not into
that type of music
it can still get
you on a variety
of other emotional chords.
And so Con Bro Chill, a small
up-and-coming party rock band
is someone that I
draw inspiration,
given the sort of counterculture
nature my business.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOEY MUCHA: Definitely.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah, it's fun.
LOGAN URY: So I'm sure a
lot of people come up to
and say, oh, you know I want
to do the same thing as you.
I want to be an entrepreneur.
What are some of the mistakes
that you see people making?
JOEY MUCHA: I kind of hinted
on it a little bit earlier
but it's either thinking you
can't succeed because you don't
have something right
away, and then not
pouring your heart and soul and
being prepared for opportunity.
I think success is your
intersection of preparedness
and opportunity.
And it's sort of
a two-way street.
The opportunity arises
when you're prepared.
And you're prepared, and
the opportunity arises,
you will achieve success.
And so I saw this
catapulting itself
in my mind and my business
when I put myself in position
by being, if you google skeeball
rentals in San Francisco,
number one result.
And across the country
I'm on the first page.
But some producer googled
that unique term in New York
and found me and
then wanted to put me
on a TV show on
the Travel Channel.
I was prepared for
the opportunity.
And then when the
opportunity presented itself
I was able to execute on it.
LOGAN URY: What happened
with the Travel Channel show?
JOEY MUCHA: So they were doing
a new series called "Game On,
America" where they
bring in a host that
is a Casino counterfeit spotter.
He can figure out who's
cheating in casinos.
And he would go around and teach
people how to excel in games.
And they said, we would
like you to teach the host
how to play skeeball and how
to hustle someone in skeeball.
And then they came to San
Francisco and filmed for a day.
And I was on the pilot--
or the very first episode
of the show-- for about six
minutes teaching the host how
to play skeeball and hustle
a group of bystanders.
LOGAN URY: Did it lead
to a lot of new business?
JOEY MUCHA: I don't
think it directly
correlated with new business.
But it definitely-- it
legitimized my status
as someone just beyond
a skeeball league.
It's like OK, this person is
a teacher as well as a player.
LOGAN URY: So you've
already accomplished
so much as Joey the Cat.
What's next?
JOEY MUCHA: So the business,
as I mentioned, is a commodity.
You can go out and buy an arcade
game today and put it in a bar.
You can buy an arcade game today
and put it up on Craigslist
to have people come rent
it, whatever you want to do.
But I see the business growing,
both from its nostalgic nature
but also I want to introduce
a little bit of innovation
into the company.
And so I'm working on
some cashless payment
systems for the games.
I think there's a
lot of opportunity
there, credit
cards specifically.
And working with
an engineer on that
is taking up a lot of my time.
And so I actually want to
hire someone and train someone
to take on some of
the day-to-day stuff
that I'm doing.
And that's a big step.
I have some
commission-only salespeople
under the team right now.
But to hire a full-time
employee to do what I'm doing
is definitely a near-term
next step for the business.
LOGAN URY: That's
really exciting.
Well that's it for my questions.
Is there anyone in the
audience who has a question?
How many machines
do you own, Joey?
JOEY MUCHA: So I own
25 skeeball machines--
LOGAN URY: Wow.
JOEY MUCHA: --just
like the one you
see here, the classic
10-Footer with mesh nets,
the 100-point pockets, and
the old-school aesthetic
that you remember from Chuck
E Cheese and the boardwalk.
LOGAN URY: Question was
why don't you aim for 100
and why is that hard.
JOEY MUCHA: So the
100-point pocket
is the highest point value
pocket on the scoring board.
And it's in the
position in the corners
where not only is it
farther away from any
of the other
pockets, it's smaller
in diameter, which does
a couple of things.
It makes it more
volatile for the ball
to actually create a
smooth entry point.
And the ball needs to be
moving at a certain inertia
to go into it smoothly.
And so to be able
to control it, it's
kind of like hitting for a home
run every time in baseball.
You're going to either miss
the ball completely or make
marginal contact.
But some of the time you're
going to make it a home run
and you're going to go straight
into the 100-point pocket.
But no one has perfected
it to go straight
into the 100-point pocket.
And it's purely the geometry
and the physics of this game.
And so the only way that
I've seen a lot of success
with the 100-point
pocket is off the net
because it does two things.
It slows the ball down
and it softens the angle.
What they do in the
national championships
is they actually tighten
the nets to the point
where it's basically a
hitting a concrete wall
and you're not going
to get it to go in.
And so it's just such
a volatile pocket
to go for that you're going
to really create a lot of risk
and a wide delta in
your scoring range.
LOGAN URY: So we're going to
have a little demonstration.
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah so I mean
every machine is different.
And that's what's the
beauty of this game
is that they all have
their own character.
But at the national
championships they tighten nets
and they use brand-new rubber
so the ball comes off really
strong.
But you basically
want to make it go off
the side net like that.
See how it comes
off the side net?
And then you slow the ball--
it slows the ball down.
So you got to find
the right angle.
And sometimes
people will actually
go off the-- there
we go-- so see
how it comes off
the net right there.
There, see how it almost
went in right there?
It's tough.
That's why I don't
go for hundreds.
Of course, the last one goes in.
But yeah, it slows the ball down
to the point where it basically
makes it easier for it to enter.
And so whenever I go to
an arcade or boardwalk
I'll definitely try to
find the machine that
has the easiest
nets to go after.
LOGAN URY: So the
question is how much
is your success in business tied
to your success as a player.
JOEY MUCHA: So the success
as a player, in my mind,
is a novelty and nice to have.
But what it did do
is it definitely
kept my morale high
as the entrepreneur.
Winning was definitely
gratification.
When you put so much
time and energy--
I've calculated I've probably
played 5,000 or 6,000
hours of skeeball,
not only being
a student of the game but
dissecting the machines,
breaking them.
A big piece of advice I
have for entrepreneurs
is to break it to
see how it works.
Whether that's a car, a bicycle,
whatever you're working with,
learn how they actually work.
Because then if you're not
an expert playing the game
you can be an expert as a
mover and creator of the game.
LOGAN URY: I think
that's a great point.
Because it's a little
intimidating to
think about becoming national
champion of something.
But you can be the
best at deconstructing
a skeeball machine
even if you're not--
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah.
LOGAN URY: --the best player.
JOEY MUCHA: If I would
have spent all my time
I did practicing to
play the game learning
how to create my own
skeeball machine I'd probably
have a really killer skeeball
machine or something that
is even more interesting
than this game.
And you need to be prepared
to go down that path,
that you don't necessarily
know the outcome.
You can't train to be a
skeeball national champion
and assume you're
going to win it.
There's a lot of risk
and luck involved there.
So what I did was I worked
really hard selling.
I worked really hard selling and
I worked really hard building
relationships, throwing parties,
and creating my own demand.
And so if you ask people
they will give you an answer.
And you've got to
be ready for no.
And you've got ready
for adversity in sales.
But a lot of people
will say yes.
And a lot of people
will want to help you.
LOGAN URY: The
question is do you ever
wish that skeeball
machines were more portable
and were surprised
that there isn't
a more portable
version at this point.
JOEY MUCHA: Yeah so the
skeeball machines are
at this perfect intersection
of overwhelming size yet
marginally portable.
I put this in the back of my
pickup truck and drove it down.
And with some help from Logan
here we brought it upstairs.
And it didn't take that long
and it wasn't that hard.
But to be able to take
on the risk and say,
I'm going to figure out
how to move these things.
I was using Zipcar rented
trucks I never even
owned a truck for the first
90% percent of my business.
I kept my overhead
really low, to rent
one truck to move a machine
or a van to move two.
And they do break
into two parts.
There's the long lane.
And then it divides
where the scoring pockets
begin into two parts.
And it's getting creative
with the way you stack them,
the way you move
them, how you have
a helper position the machines.
And I do wish they were smaller.
But I think them being
smaller would take away
from the impact.
There are really cheap
$300 skeeball machines
that you'd have for maybe
a kid's backyard party
but they don't have
the same effect.
And so bringing this particular
arcade game out into the wild
is what gives it its novelty.
AUDIENCE: What would
this cost? $5,000?
JOEY MUCHA: New they're
$5,000 or $6,000.
They don't make
this model anymore.
So I find them online from
anywhere between $500 to $2,500
a machine.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
JOEY MUCHA: And
then one rental goes
for $600 for the
machine for a day.
So the payback period is
pretty aggressive, yeah.
LOGAN URY: One
question I have is,
do you still find playing
skeeball fun even though it's
your business.
JOEY MUCHA: That's
a great question.
I do still find it fun
because at the end of the day
it's a game.
And the fun that I find
out of it is just enjoying.
The whole reason I'm here is
because I'm playing this game.
And the friends around you.
If I was in a vacuum,
just playing by myself
as a robot just rolled
for high scores,
or trying to get that
perfect game-- 900--
I wouldn't be
having as much fun.
But I'm with my friends.
And every event that I go
to is a new opportunity
to meet somebody, to
show them my passion,
and to experience something new.
LOGAN URY: I think that's
a great place to end it.
Joey, thank you so much
for coming to Google today.
JOEY MUCHA: Thanks
for having me.
[APPLAUSE]